so the plan was to go home for just two
weeks
say hello to my friends and come back to
colorado but i knew that wasn't
happening
because they were watching me at this
time they [__] knew what was going on
so i go back to juries i got a job as a
bartender i go to the american
bartending institute
and i get a job and again i try to play
it straight because that was the whole
goal of this thing
was just like to buy me one week i just
wanted to make a score where i get an
apartment a car
and a nice furniture and a tv and i'd
get a day job i would have been a
[__] plumber
but i could never get that score you
know what i'm saying every time i got it
i snorted it
i could never so i started taking out
drug dealers that was the
at the time in the 80s when i went back
to jersey
everybody had blow and everybody had to
give it away they wanted to move it
so people come to you and say can you
get rid of coke yeah take two ounces
you're like really yeah i'll get the
money in a month
but all these people were leaving coke
at that house
and there was this one kid when i was
about 15 one night he had a he was a
rich kid like a mafia kid
and he had a z28 anybody remember z28s i
don't know if they still got him
remember the middle seat has like that
[__] bump and you had to sit like
with your ass sideways because
if not you had a hemorrhoid to your
[__] 90.
one night i went out with this kid pete
and i didn't really know him pete and
other friends and when i was in the
middle seat
and as we pull up uh he sees his
girlfriend
and she was flirting with some other guy
and i'm kind of stoned i'm in the middle
seat now
listen i'm no karate expert but i'll
fight you know i'm not gonna let you
[__] get beat up
so i don't know what he's looking at he
runs out and jumps on the guy and he
gets beat the [__] up
you know he fought some guy that was
like three years old and over some girl
by the time i know there's a fight i get
out and he's getting beat up
it's one-on-one it's fair we break it up
we go in the car he's bleeding the next
day this [__] is telling people
i'm a [__] because i didn't stick
up for him i'm like first of all you
were getting smacked when i was still in
the middle [__] aisle
when i was still in the middle seat you
had jumped out of the car and he threw
one punch the guy just looked at him the
guy bit slapped him 18 times
i go i didn't jump in the other four
guys in the car you were fighting them
fair and square but
i approached him and i told him this and
he had like an attitude so i left him
the [__] alone and i always knew i would
catch this [__]
i always knew i would catch this
[__] now the father had left a
mother
he lived in a house with his mother and
his aunt his mother worked in the city
and his aunt stayed there all day she
was like uh not in a wheelchair but she
just was robots
she was crazy she didn't leave the house
and he slept up in the attic
and he comes up to me when he goes dog i
got a bunch of coke and i'm trying to
sell it
and this is my time to get this
[__] and my brother at the time
a kid that i was tight with
had bit slapped them years earlier so
nobody really liked each other
he came to me and i'm like this is my
time to rob this guy it's like
i don't know nobody's got blow you know
nobody goes yes you do whatever
you know who snorts you you gotta help
me so like two days late i called my
buddy go listen perry's selling coke
let's go down and rob this [__]
i pull up and he's at work and only the
ant is in the house
i go to the screen door and i'm a big
guy but at this time i was like 180 190
i wasn't a big guy
but i'm light [__] on my feet i could
fly to the [__] air you know what i'm
saying like i'm light
so i go into the front door they always
they didn't close the door they left the
screen door
so i go into the front door the aunt
doesn't hear me i go all the way up to
the attic and when i walk in
there's a grinder and a box and i take
them both
and i [__] leave but i had to think
this out i'm like this motherfucker's
gonna come looking for me
or one of my friends so what i did was i
went to the neighborhood deli hash way
he was a [__] gossip chick
you know what i'm saying you know those
guys that gossip all day and i went in
there and purposely asked them for a 20
because i didn't have money to get home
i had money in my pocket plus i had his
money in the coke
because i knew his first reaction was go
up to hash ways and ask hashway
has any of these guys been here my house
just got robbed and he said yeah coco
just left me borrowed 20
to go home and the guy would go i think
he did it he goes why would he borrow
twenty dollars
follow me so i go home to my apartment
i'm living downtown i stash the coke
because i know he's coming
part of being a good criminal is knowing
the outcome that's what life should be
before you make a move
you should see the outcome and how
you're going to get caught so you don't
avoid that
so i get home and i can't even do the
coke because he's going to come down
he's going to know i'm cooked up
i got so i did like a little bump and
jerked off for a little while i was in
the afternoon
so my bed was against this wall
it wasn't really a bed it was a couch i
had a bedroom but you didn't sleep in
those days it was just clothes on the
floor
i had to pull out couch and i'd sleep
there and watch tv and there was two
windows
i'm laying on the couch and i see a
shadow in the window
and i'm like here he is this is him
coming to put his ear in the glass
but the window is open so i stand to the
side
and all of a sudden i see his leg come
through the [__] window
and i'm going and i could kick him there
but i go let me just because i gotta
throw in a [__] window it was
like two floors down at that point
he climbed through the stairway and it
was like a little thing like a little
ledge where
you put little [__] flower pots and
[__] so he was doing this
so i could have pushed him off that
[__] but so i waited till he put
his leg in my window and i cocked his
[__] arm
and he didn't like this and he went to
turn around and as he turned around
this came right at him and he [__]
went down
and i punched him like eight times like
what the [__] are you doing here
[__] i turned on him
he's like you robbed my house i'm gonna
rob [__] i've been home all [__] day
and about 20 dollars from hash way you
dumb [__] he's like well get in
the car with me because my aunt said
she's seen you
or something let's go see you're [__]
there yeah it's [__] what are you
talking about
anthony c [__] nobody she got thick
glasses how the [__] you gonna say
so we go up there and the ant's like no
that's not him and he's like i know it's
him
he was busy i know it's you [__]
i'm like
there's nothing you could do about it so
just [__] drop it and in those days
that was my revenge on people
like my revenge was really [__]
we're going to get yours one day we're
going to rob your ass
because i hung out with these savages
there was another guy named mike
and he sold really good coke but he was
getting 60 a half a gram then
it was 120 gram it was 100 everywhere
else
this guy wanted 120 and i had a guy who
used to give me so many trinitrons
i'm taking you [__] old school
now brand new sony trinitrons and he
would give him to me for 60 cash
and they were like 300 at the time and i
would bring him to him and he'd give me
a half a gram of coke
a little more so ozzy osbourne was
playing this is right after randy rhodes
dies right
ozzy osbourne was playing the metal
lands with the other guitar player and i
go [__] let's go down there
i had a trinitron at the house and i was
waiting for somebody else i go [__] it
it's sunday
we'll take the trinitron to mike and
he'll give us a half a gram at least
we'll have some coke for the concert
i take the television over there you
know what this [__] says to me
goes
nah tonight you're only getting a
quarter grand
i go for a year we've been bringing you
tv she goes not new rules
i go doug i'm going to see ozzy osbourne
have a little [__] sympathy here you
know i'm saying
how am i going to walk in there with a
quarter grand with two [__] people
and he goes bro if you don't like it go
[__] yourself i said you know what take
the tv
on the way out we're gonna rob this
[__]
i waited a year to get this hook face
[__] he's one of those guys that
has one of those hooks that goes down
off his face like that right
and i would see him and wave how are you
doing yeah one night we went over there
we were desperate for blow so we went
over there
and we went over boom i bought the coke
from he's like how you doing you haven't
been whining when i got
busy i gotta pee he goes go to the
bathroom when i went to the bathroom i
went to leave the bathroom window open
because listen when you're a burglar
rule number one hit the bathroom window
it's always open when you're in the
shower get steamed what do you do you
open it you're not gonna [__] close
and put the thing in
bathroom window always open i went over
and checked
[__] wide open i walk out i go bro
thanks to see you i go back
i start snorting the coke with this kid
russo we snort all the [__] coke
and also we're like what are we gonna do
now i'm like i don't know bro
i go let's walk down and rob this
[__] guy and he's like no i'm like i
left the window open it's done come on
let's go
so i go back down it's [__] one in
the morning he's out of the concert at
some
dance club or something i climb into the
[__] bathroom window i go down i let
my buddy into the front door
we rummage the [__] house nothing
not a seed that was like 30 in cash
we walk out of there like [__] broken
hearted like
and the coke were off you know what i'm
saying like we did that last line
because we thought we're gonna get more
now the coke were off and we're walking
last night look i'm gonna go [__] that
that coke is in that [__] house i go
back in
i open up the sink and there's a little
tupperware
and i open it up and it was filled to
the [__] brim with the [__] blow
i'm like that's it this is ours i take
it we stay up all night saturday night
all night sunday night and finally
monday morning i go home
i got like maybe a couple grams left
monday morning that afternoon i'm
lifting weights with my brother
and some other guy and the door knocks
and it's the kid we robbed
and he's like where's mike but he wasn't
looking for me
because i guess that night when i went
another kid my brother had gone over
there too that night
he blamed my brother
so i'm i'm in the back with stinky
lifting and he knows that i rob mike
we're giggling our asses off like mike's
getting the blame right
he comes back he's like i threw those
[__] out they blaming me i
didn't steal this [__] coke
i'm sitting there dying of [__]
laughter
and this poor guy standing getting the
blame and finally i felt bad and i had
to tell him
listen it was us that robbed him we'll
give you a gram
now that was 1982
it is 2012. do you know when i go to
jersey i still see that guy we robbed
and he's still [__] up and he comes up
to me all the time he goes how you doing
you know i'm still making payments on
that ounce you robbed from me 30 years
ago
he goes i never forgot that why did you
rob me and i'm to this day i'm like dog
it was mike
[Applause]
you know cause i got blamed for a lot of
[__] i didn't [__] do too
that's the other thing like once you
have a reputation
they [__] blame you for everything
that's the reason why i left jersey
that's why i ended up in colorado
but it's funny because for all that i'm
telling you guys it was it was
embarrassing and it's embarrassing for
me to tell you guys these stories but
it's like [__] psychotherapy for me
right now because now i've already got
them off my chest you know